Shure: 找个
Shure: Find a...
Shure: 稍微大一点的碗
Shure: A slightly bigger bowl.
Shure: 这个哎这个好
Shure: This one, oh, this is good.
Alice: 你要干嘛
Alice: What are you going to do?
Shure: 打两个鸡蛋
Shure: Crack two eggs.
Shure: 然后裹个蛋液
Shure: Then coat it with egg wash.
Alice: 我来吧你刷好了没
Alice: Let me do it, did you wash it well?
Shure: 你看好了没
Shure: Did you look at it?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Alice: 你会打吗
Alice: Can you crack it?
Shure: 我会啊
Shure: Yes, I can.
Shure: 呵这单手打蛋可以啊
Shure: Haha, cracking an egg with one hand, no problem.
Shure: 可以吧
Shure: Not bad, right?
Alice: 拿个筷子
Alice: Get some chopsticks.
Shure: 多帅
Shure: So cool.
Alice: 你要煎鸡蛋
Alice: Are you going to fry the egg?
Alice: 不要
Alice: No.
Shure: 煎也行一会煎
Alice: 嗯有个蛋壳皮
Alice: Hmm, there's a piece of eggshell.
Alice: 你要煎鸡蛋吗
Alice: Are you going to fry some eggs?
Shure: 嗯煎两个
Shure: Yeah, fry two.
Shure: 油稍微热热
Shure: Heat up the oil a bit.
Alice: 没锅铲好像
Alice: Seems like there's no spatula.
Shure: 拿筷子翻一下
Shure: Use chopsticks to flip it.
Alice: 筷子筷子
Alice: Chopsticks, chopsticks.
Shure: 我先给刷出来
Alice: 不刷啊哦
Alice: No, I won't clean it.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Alice: 刷过的
Alice: It's already cleaned.
Shure: 刷过的
Shure: It's already cleaned.
Shure: 锅好像有点粘
Shure: The pan seems to be sticking.
Shure: 垃圾锅
Shure: Trash pan.
Shure: 所以真没有锅铲是吗
Shure: So there's really no spatula?
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 牛逼
Shure: Awesome.
Alice: 竟连个锅铲都没有
Alice: Can't believe there's no spatula.
Shure: 早上好
Shure: Good morning.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina:  在干什么呀
Katrina: What are you doing?
Alice: 唉艰难呀
Alice: Ah, it's tough.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh no.
Shure: 这锅太次了
Shure: This pan is terrible.
Shure: 我受不了了
Shure: I can't take it anymore.
Alice: 还没锅铲
Alice: Still no spatula.
Shure: 还没锅铲
Shure: Still no spatula.
Shure: 这是不是啊
Shure: Is this it?
Shure: 这呢吗这不锅铲
Shure: Isn't this a spatula?
Katrina: 洗洁精
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 洗洁精
Shure: 他他都快撞你脸上了都哈哈
Shure: It almost hit your face, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈糟了
Katrina: Hahaha, oh no.
Shure: 擦一下擦一下
Shure: Wipe it, wipe it.
Shure: 现在有水
Shure: There's water now.
Katrina:  要不直接洗碗吧
Katrina: Why not just wash the dishes?
Katrina:  反正湿了
Katrina: Since it's already wet.
Alice: 这蛋已经糊的没法看了
Alice: This egg is burnt beyond recognition.
Alice: 那一面
Alice: That side.
Shure: 那你先关了吧
Shure: Then turn it off first.
Katrina:  啥呀鸡蛋吗
Katrina: What, the eggs?
Shure: 是的
Shure: 哎嘿嘿
Shure: Hehe
Alice: 糊的要命
Alice: It's so burnt
Alice: 真服了
Alice: Seriously, I'm done
Shure: 是不是油少了
Shure: Is it because there's not enough oil?
Alice: 也不少吧
Alice: Not really
Shure: 对啊这有点吃油感觉
Shure: Yeah, it feels like it needs more oil
Shure: 哎呀妈我一会都不敢不敢煎了都
Shure: Oh man, I'm scared to fry it now
Alice: 再放点来得及
Alice: Add a bit more, it's still time
Shure: 再倒点吧
Shure: Pour a bit more
Shure: 这锅有点粘的话就多倒点吧
Shure: If the pan is sticky, just add more oil
Shure: 没办法呀
Shure: There's no other way
Shure: 还给你剩点
Shure: I'll leave some for you
Katrina:  什么呀那是肉吗
Katrina: What, is that even meat?
Shure: 不是我说收拾一下哈哈
Shure: No, I meant clean it up, haha
Katrina:  我昨晚那个写写报告去
Katrina: I was writing that report last night
Katrina:  写到5点
Katrina: Wrote until 5 AM
Shure: 啊
Shure: Wow
Katrina:  写到5点钟
Katrina: Until 5 in the morning
Katrina:  然后刚醒
Katrina: And just woke up
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn
Shure: 太牛了
Shure: That's impressive
Katrina:  总感觉每天这小小段的时间写不好
Katrina: I always feel like I can't write well in such short time
Katrina:  然后影响我的心情
Katrina: And it affects my mood
Katrina:  还不如通宵一晚上
Katrina: Might as well stay up all night
Shure: 牛
Shure: 行了给它捞出来吧
Shure: Okay, let's take it out
Shure: 这肯定熟了
Shure: It's definitely cooked
Alice: 也是这样吗
Alice: Is it like this?
Shure: 对蛋黄也熟
Shure: Yeah, the yolk is cooked too
Alice: 你不撒你不放盐吗
Alice: Aren't you adding salt?
Alice: 哦你撒盐吗
Alice: Oh, are you adding salt?
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure: 没撒沾酱油也行
Shure: I didn't, but dipping in soy sauce works too
Alice: 我们没酱油
Alice: We don't have soy sauce
Shure: 我们今天早上补给了
Katrina:  昨天晚上小蛋糕都吃完了吗
Katrina: Did you finish the little cakes last night?
Katrina:  嗯昨天晚上小蛋糕都吃完了吗
Katrina: Hmm, did you finish the little cakes last night?
Alice: 没有还有点
Alice: No, there's still some left
Katrina:  放哪放冰箱了吗
Katrina: Where did you put them, in the fridge?
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm hmm
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: 我真的没想到煎个蛋都这么费劲
Shure: I really didn't expect frying an egg to be so troublesome.
Katrina:  这锅的问题
Katrina: It's the pan's problem.
Shure: 这哎呦
Shure: Oh, come on.
Katrina:  不是你们的问题
Katrina: It's not your fault.
Shure: 我不信了
Shure: I don't believe it.
Shure: 奶奶个腿的
Shure: Damn it.
Alice: 现在几点
Alice: What time is it now?
Shure: 我来
Shure: I'll do it.
Shure: 那边可以了是吗
Shure: Is it done over there?
Katrina:  闷一会吧
Katrina: Let it sit for a while.
Shure: 差不多了已经
Shure: It's almost done.
Alice: 我就已经放了很多油了
Alice: I've already put a lot of oil.
Alice: 这是炸蛋
Alice: This is like a deep-fried egg.
Shure: 管他呢
Shure: Whatever.
Shure: 多来点嘛
Shure: Add more.
Shure: 不行
Shure: No, it's not working.
Alice: 我在这里放的油是我在家里放的两倍
Alice: The amount of oil I put here is twice as much as at home.
Shure: 我也是
Shure: Same here.
Shure: 我我们家就是
Shure: At home, we don't really use much oil.
Shure: 其实不怎么吃油太大
Shure: Actually, we don't really eat very greasy food.
Alice: 这个锅要是没太多油的话
Alice: If this pan didn't have so much oil,
Alice: 估计要
Alice: it would probably...
Shure: 要干吧死
Shure: ...dry up and burn.
Alice: 粘成成棉花糖
Alice: ...stick like cotton candy.
Shure: 不信了
Shure: I don't believe it.
Shure: 今天连个好的蛋都煎不出来吗
Shure: Can't we even fry a good egg today?
Shure: 我不认可
Shure: I refuse to accept this.
Shure: 炸蛋
Shure: Deep-fried egg.
Alice: 还粘吗
Alice: Still sticking?
Shure: 不粘了这次
Shure: Not sticking this time.
Shure: 行应该能成型了这回
Shure: Looks like it should hold its shape this time.
Shure: （歌词）we are the champion my friend
Shure: (Singing) We are the champions, my friend.
Alice: 吃一个煎蛋一天的油量已经够了
Alice: Eating one fried egg is enough oil for a day.
Shure: 卧槽太不容易了
Shure: Damn, this is not easy.
Alice: 基本就是靠油把这个蛋跟铁隔开
Alice: Basically, we are using oil to keep the egg from sticking to the pan.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yep.
Shure: 可以牛逼的
Shure: It's possible, it can work.
Alice:你这个不煎好再下下一个吗
Alice: If this one doesn't turn out well, fry another one?
Shure: 不用煎下
Shure: No need to fry another.
Shure: 下下一个就行
Shure: The next one will be fine.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 再补补钙
Shure: Let's get some more calcium.
Shure: 完了这摊子太太大了
Shure: Oh no, this is getting too big.
Shure: OK那个可以了
Shure: OK, that’s good.
Shure: 那个可以拿出来
Shure: You can take that out.
Shure: 我来我来我来
Shure: I got it, I got it.
Alice: 拿筷子夹吧
Alice: Use chopsticks to pick it up.
Shure: 完美的煎蛋
Shure: Perfectly fried egg.
Shure: （歌词）一起舞蹈没有烦恼
Shure: (Lyrics) Dance together, no worries.
Alice: 这么多油还在粘锅
Alice: So much oil and it still sticks?
Alice: 家用的锅
Alice: It's a household pan.
Alice: 喷两下那个油壶就能煎出来
Alice: Just spray some oil and it'll fry nicely.
Alice: 完美无缝的蛋
Alice: Perfect, seamless egg.
Alice: 忍一下算了
Alice: Just bear with it.
Shure: 我只能说不忍直视
Shure: I just can't stand to look at it.
Alice: 你那面包还煎不煎
Alice: Are you going to toast your bread or not?
Shure: 煎
Shure: 遇到困难我们不能不能低头
Katrina:  我不用煎
Katrina: I don't need to.
Katrina:  我直接吃就行好
Katrina: I can just eat it as is.
Shure: 妈呀这洗衣机真够小的
Shure: Gosh, this washing machine is so small.
Shure: 塞两件衣服它就满了
Shure: Just two pieces of clothing and it's full.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh man.
Shure: 你怎么还漏出来
Shure: Why is it still leaking?
Shure: 本来挺好
Shure: It was fine before.
Shure: 我他妈恨不得弄死你
Shure: I could just kill you right now.
Shure: 把这些碎蛋渣都吃了
Shure: Eat all these egg crumbs.
Shure: 这样就我没有煎过这些碎的
Shure: So it looks like I never fried these broken pieces.
Shure: 销毁一下证据
Shure: Destroy the evidence.
Alice: 来
Alice: Here.
Alice: 帮我把这个拿走
Alice: Help me take this away.
Alice: 过冷水
Alice: Rinse with cold water.
Shure: 用过冷水吗
Shure: Rinse with cold water?
Alice:啊
Alice: Yes.
Shure: 啊用过冷水吗
Shure: Yes, rinse with cold water?
Alice: 不用过冷水
Alice: No need to rinse with cold water.
Shure: 都行都行
Shure: Either way is fine.
Shure: 荷包蛋
Shure: Poached egg.
Shure: you know i'm sighing
Shure: You know I'm sighing.
Shure: （歌词）一起舞蹈没烦恼
Shure: (Lyrics) Dancing together, no worries.
Shure: 哎他们难道没用黄油吗
Shure: Hey, didn't they use butter?
Katrina:  楼上有奶酪啊
Katrina: There's cheese upstairs.
Katrina:  刚买了奶酪
Katrina: Just bought some cheese.
Shure: 用黄油煎面包香香
Shure: Toasting bread with butter smells so good.
Katrina:  这可乐是昨天晚上开的是吧
Katrina: This Coke was opened last night, right?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Yeah, that's right.
Shure: 做那什么的
Shure: For making something.
Alice: 讲究啊
Alice: Fancy!
Alice: 用黄油煎
Alice: Using butter to toast.
Shure: 他要香一些的
Shure: It makes it more fragrant.
Shure: 但是这黄油好难拆啊
Shure: But this butter is so hard to open.
Shure: 我靠这黄油口在这边
Shure: Damn, the opening is on this side.
Shure: 这怎么
Shure: How do I...
Shure: 弄他呀啊
Shure: ...deal with this?
Shure: 不是上切
Shure: Don't cut from the top.
Shure: 就是切下来的意思
Shure: Just cut it off.
Shure: 对对对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice: 切一块嘿嘿
Alice: Cut a piece, hehe.
Shure: 来吧上刀
Shure: Come on, get the knife.
Shure: 啊刀不在这边
Katrina:  刀在这呢
Katrina: The knife is here.
Shure: 我早上刷的
Alice: 那你直接用吧
Alice: Just use it directly then.
Katrina:  你搁这呗
Katrina: Put it here.
Alice: 呃呃呃这不是烤那蛋糕的那个
Alice: Umm, isn't this for baking the cake?
Shure: 啊有道理
Shure: Ah, makes sense.
Alice: 你把这个抠下来
Alice: Just scoop this out.
Alice: 然后这个还能当盖盖上不上
Alice: Then you can use this as a lid.
Shure: 呵呵呵好
Shure: Haha, alright.
Shure: 你说的对
Shure: You're right.
Shure: 早上好
Shure: Good morning.
Alice: 知道煎什么吗
Alice: Do you know what to toast?
Shure: 煎面包
Shure: Bread.
Shure: 哎我刚才拿出来面包呢
Shure: Hey, I just took out the bread.
Katrina:  这些东西都放哪了呀
Katrina: Where did you put all the stuff?
Alice: 怎么这呢啊
Alice: Over here.
Shure: 这呢啊
Shure: It's here.
Shure: 随便放底下就行
Shure: Just put it down here.
Alice: 你这衣服是要洗的吗
Alice: Are these clothes to be washed?
Alice: 你没开啊
Alice: Did you not turn it on?
Shure: 是的啊对对
Shure: Yes, right.
Shure: 我等一会弄完了
Shure: I'll do it later.
Shure: 啊行
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure: 你帮我倒了点洗衣液
Shure: Can you pour some laundry detergent for me?
Shure: 然后开了就行
Shure: Then just start it.
Shure: 面包忒油了
Shure: The bread is too oily.
Shure: 稍微炖出去点
Shure: Let's stew it a bit more.
Shure: 哇好多蚂蚁啊
Shure: Wow, so many ants!
Katrina:  我去真的这边
Katrina: Oh my, really over here.
Alice: 吃鸡蛋吗
Alice: Want some eggs?
Alice: 微微
Alice: Tasha?
Tasha: 生鸡蛋
Tasha: Raw eggs.
Tasha: 哦哦水煮蛋
Tasha: Oh, oh, boiled eggs.
Shure: 水煮蛋
Shure: Boiled eggs.
Shure: 早起一杯黑咖啡是吗
Shure: A cup of black coffee in the morning, right?
Shure: 尝一个
Shure: Try one.
Tasha: 鸡鸡蛋
Tasha: Chicken eggs.
Shure: 这是煎的面包片
Shure: These are fried bread slices.
Shure: 对煎的面包片
Shure: Yes, fried bread slices.
Shure: 杨老板呢
Shure: Where's Jake?
Tasha: 鲜牛奶应该可以吧
Tasha: Fresh milk should be okay, right?
Shure: 早上好
Shure: Good morning.
Katrina:  昨天有买新的吗
Katrina: Did we buy new ones yesterday?
Tasha: 另一瓶喝完了吗
Tasha: Did we finish the other bottle?
Katrina:  本来就是
Katrina: Actually, yes.
Katrina:  上一次买两瓶
Katrina: We bought two bottles last time.
Katrina:  一瓶已经喝完了
Katrina: One bottle is already finished.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake?
Shure: 尝尝面包呗杨老板
Shure: Try some bread, Jake.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 先对个齐
Jake: Let's align it first.
Jake: 来
Jake: Here.
Shure: 面包蘸番茄酱
Shure: Bread dipped in ketchup.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  为什么拧不开
Katrina: Why can't I open this?
Tasha: 还有人要喝牛奶吗
Tasha: Anyone else want milk?
Tasha: 好吧没有
Tasha: Okay, no one.
Lucia: 我可以喝
Lucia: I can have some.
Tasha: 算了我看到了
Tasha: Never mind, I see it.
Tasha: 你都已经背叛了
Tasha: You've already betrayed us.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Ah, come on.
Lucia: 等我把这这个橙汁不是柠檬汁喝完了
Lucia: Let me finish this orange juice, not lemon juice.
Lucia: 就喝
Lucia: Just drink it.
Tasha: 黄油少切一点啊
Tasha: Cut a little less butter.
Tasha: 好没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 你就切吧
Tasha: Just cut it.
Tasha: 这么多可以
Tasha: This much is fine.
Shure: 放冰箱里吧
Shure: Put it in the fridge.
Jake: 我吃哪一个呢
Jake: Which one should I eat?
Shure: 你尝个面包吧
Shure: Try a piece of bread.
Shure: 那面包嘎嘎香
Shure: That bread smells so good.
Tasha: 黄油就奶香奶香的了已经
Tasha: The butter already smells so creamy.
Shure: 是我碰到的吗
Shure: Did I bump into it?
Katrina:  不知道
Katrina: I don't know.
Shure: 他他怎么掉的
Shure: How did it fall?
Tasha: 看摄像头
Tasha: Check the camera.
Jake: 回头看摄像头
Jake: We'll check the camera later.
Shure: 不是这必须掉下VCR
Shure: It must have fallen off the VCR.
Shure: 我啊这窜下去的是吧
Shure: Did I kick it down?
Katrina:  把杯子放在这上
Katrina: Put the cup here.
Jake: 这位置扫一扫
Jake: Sweep this area.
Tasha: 天呐摔了几个
Tasha: Oh my, how many fell?
Shure: 不是他应该会掉到我的
Shure: It should have fallen into my...
Shure: 鞋里吧啊
Shure: Shoe, right?
Tasha: 啊你抖一抖
Tasha: Shake it out.
Shure: 我抖一抖
Shure: I'll shake it out.
Shure: 你把面包再给我
Shure: Give me the bread again.
Shure: 我再煎一片面包
Shure: I'll fry another piece.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina:  我们有扫帚吗
Katrina: Do we have a broom?
Tasha: 煎一片还是两片
Tasha: Fry one piece or two?
Tasha: 这么多黄油
Tasha: So much butter.
Tasha: 就煎一片
Tasha: Just one piece.
Jake: 在哪来着
Jake: Where is it?
Shure: 没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Tasha: 哦哦还有裹蛋糕液
Tasha: Oh, there's also cake batter.
Shure: 好吃吗这个还行吧
Shure: Is this good? It's okay, right?
Tasha: 好吃
Tasha: Delicious.
Lucia: 特别香
Lucia: Really fragrant.
Shure: 其实你要想吃甜的就再撒点糖
Shure: If you want it sweeter, just add some more sugar.
Shure: 可以的
Shure: It's fine.
Jake: 都是凶器啊
Jake: These are all lethal weapons.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 就告诉大家这都是危险物品
Shure: Just tell everyone these are dangerous items.
Shure: 杨老板在新加坡自己给自己做吃的吗
Shure: Jake, do you cook for yourself in Singapore?
Jake: 不给开火
Jake: No, no cooking allowed.
Jake: 屋里不给开火
Jake: No cooking allowed inside.
Shure: 从来没开过火是吗
Shure: You've never cooked before, right?
Jake: 屋里不给开火
Jake: No cooking allowed inside.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 就是就是
Jake: Yep, yep.
Jake: 没开过火
Jake: Never cooked.
Jake: 确实没开过火
Jake: Really never cooked.
Alice: 抖抖吧
Alice: Shake it.
Alice: 你不得往下抖吗
Alice: You need to shake it down.
Alice: 你前面又出不去
Alice: You can't get out from the front.
Shure: 应该
Shure: Probably.
Alice: 劝你穿个袜子
Alice: I suggest you wear some socks.
Shure: 应该问题不大没事
Shure: It should be fine, no worries.
Jake: 去检查一下
Jake: Go check it out.
Shure: 行我一会去厕所检查一下
Shure: Okay, I'll check it out in the bathroom later.
Shure: 盘子端过来一下把这拿
Shure: Bring the plate over, take this.
Lucia: 用这煎蛋盘可以吗
Lucia: Can I use this egg frying pan?
Shure: 煎蛋也可以吃
Shure: You can eat fried eggs too.
Shure: 但煎蛋没有
Shure: But we don't have any.
Shure: 没没撒盐
Shure: Didn't, didn't add salt.
Lucia: 那就先用这盘盛一下吧
Lucia: Let's use this plate for now.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 没了
Shure: That's it.
Lucia:  先放过去了是吧
Lucia: So, you already put it over there?
Shure: 对放过去了
Shure: Yes, it's over there.
Tasha: AI拍了短片
Tasha: AI made a short video.
Alice: 露西你帮我把它倒在这里面吧
Alice: Lucia, can you pour it in here for me?
Jake: 有咖啡喝吗
Jake: Is there any coffee?
Shure: 有咖啡豆倒了
Katrina:  我也要
Katrina: I want some too.
Shure: 你也要是吗
Shure: You want some too?
Shure: 等等等管家送来
Shure: Wait, wait, the butler will bring it.
Shure: 他大概什么时候送来
Shure: When will he bring it?
Jake: 他是不是已经送来了
Jake: Has he already brought it?
Jake: 你看看那边有没有啊
Jake: Check over there, see if it's there.
Alice: 在这
Alice: Here.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 没送来吧这不是
Shure: It hasn't been delivered, has it?
Shure: 不是没没有新的快递
Shure: No, there are no new deliveries.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 所以另一袋面包去哪了
Shure: So where did the other bag of bread go?
Lucia: 那我再洗个手
Lucia: I'll wash my hands again.
Jake: 打碎了3个杯子
Jake: I broke three cups.
Jake: 几个杯子
Jake: How many cups?
Alice: 笔跟纸是不是不在这
Alice: Are the pen and paper not here?
Jake: 饼干
Jake: Cookies.
Jake: 什么纸
Jake: What paper?
Alice: 便签跟
Alice: Post-it notes and...
Shure: 另一袋面包去哪了
Shure: Where did the other bag of bread go?
Jake:后面看看
Shure: 你有看到另一袋面包吗
Shure: Did you see the other bag of bread?
Katrina: 另 一袋面包
Katrina: Another bag of bread?
Shure: 你要偷吃了我们不怪你的
Shure: If you stole it, we won't blame you.
Shure: 你就大方的说就好
Shure: Just be honest about it.
Katrina:  没有我昨天放冰箱的呀
Katrina: No, I put it in the fridge yesterday.
Katrina:  都没有吗
Katrina: It's not there?
Katrina:  居然
Katrina: Really?
Shure: 真没不是
Shure: It's really not there.
Shure: 好奇怪丢了一袋面包
Shure: So strange, a bag of bread is missing.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 难受
Shure: This sucks.
Shure: 对咱们昨天没吃
Shure: Yeah, we didn't eat it yesterday.
Shure: 而昨天生蚝忘吃了
Shure: And we forgot to eat the oysters yesterday.
Shure: 该补的忘补了
Shure: Forgot to make up for it.
Shure: 现在感觉整个人身体被掏空
Shure: Now I feel completely drained.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 廉价的快乐没有享受得到
Jake: Couldn't enjoy the simple pleasures.
Tasha: 蒜蒜蒜蓉生蚝
Tasha: Garlic, garlic, garlic oysters.
Lucia: 哦蒜蓉粉丝那种
Lucia: Oh, the ones with garlic and vermicelli.
Jake: 那再蒸点
Jake: Then let's steam some more.
Jake: 再蒸三刀
Jake: Steam three more.
Tasha: 有那个蒸笼呀
Tasha: We have a steamer.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 很好蒸的
Tasha: It's easy to steam.
Jake: 得有得有
Jake: Got it, got it.
Jake: 生蚝首先得有生蚝
Jake: First, you need to have oysters.
Tasha: 不是有吗
Tasha: Don't we have them?
Lucia: 昨晚是没放冰箱
Lucia: They weren't put in the fridge last night.
Jake: 对没放冰箱
Jake: Yeah, they weren't put in the fridge.
Shure: 没放冰箱就放这了
Shure: They were just left out.
Tasha: 所以生蚝多少钱
Tasha: So how much are the oysters?
Shure: 总共19块9吧
Shure: They were a total of 19.9.
Shure: 那10支大概
Shure: That's for about 10 of them.
Shure: 还行吧还行吧
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 其实是损失了多少个100新币
Jake: Actually, we lost a few hundred Singapore dollars.
Shure: 哎对对
Shure: Yeah, right, right.
Jake: 有10个吧
Jake: About ten of them.
Tasha: 我来看一下
Tasha: Let me take a look.
Jake: 报损了100新币的损失
Jake: We reported a loss of 100 Singapore dollars.
Tasha: 让我来打开订单看一下他到底多少钱
Tasha: Let me open the order and check how much it was.
Shure: 确实是19块9
Shure: It was definitely 19.9.
Shure: 然后10支
Shure: And then 10 of them.
Shure: 不到4新币
Shure: Less than 4 Singapore dollars.
Jake: 但是损失了100
Jake: But we lost 100.
Katrina:  我想尝一小片给谁
Katrina: I want to try a small piece, for whom?
Lucia: 一小片是什么
Lucia: What do you mean by a small piece?
Katrina:  就是我吃不完一整片
Katrina: I can't finish a whole piece.
Lucia: 直接撕吧没事
Lucia: Just tear it off, it's fine.
Tasha: 啊真的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 最后一个煎了
Tasha: 19块9一袋
Tasha: 19.9 for a bag.
Jake: 二楼也没有面包哈
Jake: There’s no bread on the second floor either.
Shure: 对啊好奇怪啊
Shure: Yeah, so weird.
Shure: 就活生生就丢了
Shure: It just disappeared.
Tasha: 怎么会丢掉一袋面包
Tasha: How can a bag of bread just go missing?
Lucia: 啊少了一袋吗
Lucia: Ah, is there one missing?
Lucia: 我昨天放那个蛋清液的时候
Lucia: When I was putting the egg whites in yesterday.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Lucia: 还是两袋呢
Lucia: There were two, right?
Tasha: 可是我记得昨天这个里面还有一袋啊
Tasha: But I remember there was still a bag in here yesterday.
Katrina:  对我就有两袋放冰箱了都
Katrina: Yeah, I put both bags in the fridge.
Shure: 到底是谁偷吃了
Shure: Who ate it?
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Katrina:  这不是吗这后面
Katrina: Here it is, behind this.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 原来你没偷吃啊
Shure: So you didn't sneak any food, huh?
Shure: 对不起是我污蔑你了
Shure: Sorry, I wrongly accused you.
Shure: 啊你要找什么
Shure: Ah, what are you looking for?
Shure: 楼上吧
Shure: Upstairs, maybe.
Jake: 这哪来的
Jake: Where did this come from?
Shure: 就是在冰箱里
Shure: From the fridge.
Shure: 刚刚大家没找到
Shure: No one found it earlier.
Jake: 这么有意思
Jake: So interesting.
Shure: 藏在那个北冰洋后面呢
Shure: It was hidden behind the Arctic Ocean drink.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 从底下掏出蛋吃是吗啊对
Shure: Taking out eggs from the bottom, right?
Katrina:  对哈哈哈
Katrina: Yes, hahaha.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 完美收官
Shure: Perfect ending.
Lucia: 棒棒
Lucia: Great job.
Shure: 我去我去处理下
Shure: I'll go deal with it.
Shure: 鞋子里面
Shure: Inside the shoes.
Shure: 这段就不拍摄了吧
Shure: Let's not film this part.
Jake: 你也可以拍
Shure: 怎么拍我的玉足是吗
Shure: How to film my beautiful feet, right?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 来插管
Jake: Come on, intubate.
Alice: 我的线
Alice: My line.
Jake: 你线在这
Jake: Your line is here.
Jake: 不要着急限速
Jake: Don't rush, take it slow.
Alice: 结束了吗
Alice: Are we done?
Jake: 要插管
Jake: Intubation.
Jake: 是还没是要开始
Jake: It's not over, it's about to start.
Katrina:  他没显示电量
Katrina: It doesn't show the battery level.
Katrina:  是没电
Katrina: It's out of power.
Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Jake: 请插管啊
Jake: Please intubate.
Jake: 有多少个
Jake: How many are there?
Shure: 扎到了皮上
Shure: It just hit the skin.
Shure: 还没扎透
Shure: Didn't pierce through.
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow.
Shure: 做早饭完成了
Shure: Breakfast is done.
Shure: 太不容易了
Shure: It's really not easy.
Shure: 我们又活过了一天
Shure: We survived another day.
Shure: 就每天感觉把自己又养活一天
Shure: It feels like we manage to feed ourselves every day.
Shure: 非常有成就感
Shure: Feels really accomplished.
Shure: 你不觉得吗
Shure: Don't you think?
Jake: 那个有那个生命条是吧
Jake: That one has a health bar, right?
Shure: 什么吃面条
Shure: What, eating noodles?
Jake: 就是每个人头上一个生命条
Jake: Everyone has a health bar above their head.
Jake: 刚起床的时候大概到到个20吧
Jake: When you just wake up, it's around 20, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 哦吃完了之后到几啊
Jake: Oh, after eating, what's it at?
Lucia: 吃一口
Lucia: Take a bite.
Jake: 都是赛博人
Jake: We're all cyborgs.
Jake: 吃了一口然后生命条就能加个5
Jake: Take a bite and your health bar increases by 5.
Katrina:  差不多
Katrina: Pretty much.
Lucia: 哦噢我把自己咬了
Katrina:  生命值减减
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 怎么看着没
Shure: What's the look?
Shure: 没肉不行是吧
Shure: Can't do without meat, right?
Shure: 要咬自己的
Shure: Have to bite yourself.
Jake: 准备插管
Jake: Prepare the tube.
Jake: 给你拿充电宝
Jake: Get you a power bank.
Lucia: 主要是您您做的这面包太好吃了
Lucia: Mainly because the bread you made is so delicious.
Katrina:  是怎么做
Katrina: How did you make it?
Katrina:  就是嗯把嗯然后呢
Katrina: It's like, um, put, um, then?
Shure: 鸡蛋打了然后裹上
Shure: Crack an egg, then coat it.
Shure: 然后最好拿黄油煎
Shure: Then it's best to fry it with butter.
Katrina: 黄油直接倒
Katrina: Just pour the butter?
Shure: 就是切下来一片然后放到锅
Shure: Just cut a slice and put it in the pan.
Shure: 然后他就会化掉嘛
Shure: Then it'll melt.
Shure: 然后你再把等他化掉之后
Shure: Then wait for it to melt.
Shure: 然后你把那个面包放上
Shure: Then put the bread on it.
Shure: 学费了吗
Shure: Learned it?
Shure: 动手吧
Shure: Give it a try.
Lucia: 我的血量就会在这一直递减
Lucia: My health will keep decreasing here.
Shure: 就问问是吧哈哈
Shure: Just asking, right? Haha.
Jake: 得一直补
Jake: Need to keep replenishing.
Jake: 得插管
Jake: Need to insert the tube.
Lucia: 在一直喝那个魔法药水
Lucia: Keep drinking that magic potion.
Shure: 什么魔法药水
Shure: What magic potion?
Jake: 她掉血了啊
Jake: She's losing health.
Lucia: 好疼啊哈哈哈
Lucia: It hurts so much, hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake: 这叫中毒
Jake: This is called poisoning.
Jake: 中毒效应
Jake: Poison effect.
Shure: 你开始持续流血是吧
Shure: You're starting to bleed continuously, right?
Tasha: 可见你对这个鸡蛋咬的有多重
Tasha: Shows how hard you bit that egg.
Lucia: 不是都好久没咬到自己舌头了
Lucia: Haven't bitten your tongue in a while, huh?
Jake: 你把外头收拾收拾
Jake: Clean up the outside.
Shure: 我的咖啡
Shure: My coffee.
Shure: 我的咖啡豆
Shure: My coffee beans.
Katrina:  啊啊你这个水杯好可爱啊
Katrina: Ah, your cup is so cute!
Alice: 我的吗嗯
Alice: Mine, huh?
Alice: 这是我其中一个水杯
Alice: This is one of my cups.
Alice: 你没见过另一个
Alice: You haven't seen the other one.
Alice: 我另一个上面全是铁环
Alice: My other one is covered in metal rings.
Shure: （歌词）举起手中的酒杯
Shure: (lyrics) Raise the wine glass in your hand.
Shure: 不能睡
Shure: Can't sleep.
Shure: （歌词）只留下baby
Shure: (lyrics) Only baby left behind.
Shure: （歌词）就别问我哭了
Shure: (lyrics) Don't ask me why I cried.
Jake: 咱先把这收起来吧
Jake: Let's put this away first.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 这个没了吧
Shure: This one's done, right?
Tasha: 勺子也带上去
Shure: 好
Jake:你不能再怼一个
Jake: Can you not mess up another one?
Shure: 又得他们又得去怼
Shure: They're going to mess it up again.
Shure: 谁道了
Shure: Who said it?
Shure: check一下应该没问题
Shure: Check it, should be fine.
Katrina:  嗯就那种因为要稍微的大一点
Katrina: Yeah, because it needs to be a bit bigger.
Lucia: 其实像这个瓶子就还可以我觉得
Lucia: Actually, I think this bottle is fine.
Lucia: 嗯这个对
Lucia: Yeah, this one.
Lucia: 但是这个瓶子的话就太小了
Lucia: But this bottle is too small.
Lucia: 那天果粒橙那瓶还在吗
Lucia: Is that bottle of orange juice still there?
Alice: 果粒橙应该扔掉了
Alice: The orange juice should have been thrown away.
Alice: 嗯应该是从这里毕业了
Alice: Yeah, it probably graduated from here.
Tasha: 噢煮了这么多鸡蛋
Tasha: Oh, you boiled so many eggs.
Lucia: 因为果粒橙那个他外面这个壳不光滑所以
Lucia: Because the orange juice bottle's outer layer isn't smooth.
Tasha: 露西你要鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Lucia, do you want an egg?
Lucia: 煮鸡蛋吗
Lucia: Boiled egg?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 那我也来一个好了
Lucia: I'll have one too.
Lucia: 其实我刚刚吃了一个煎蛋
Lucia: Actually, I just had a fried egg.
Shure: 是人类可以摄取两个的一天
Shure: Humans can consume up to two a day.
Tasha: 今天是全蛋宴是吗
Tasha: Is today an egg feast or what?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Tasha: 煮蛋蒸蛋煎蛋
Tasha: Boiled eggs, steamed eggs, fried eggs.
Shure: 不
Shure: No.
Shure: 能不能辜负了护蛋使者的护蛋行动啊
Shure: We can't let down the egg protector's mission, right?
Tasha: 护蛋使者
Tasha: Egg protector?
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Tasha: 护蛋使者
Lucia: 现在就看那个串珠和欧根纱
Lucia: Now we just need to check when the beads and organza will arrive.
Lucia: 什么时候能到
Lucia: When will they get here?
Alice: 早上水煮鸡蛋
Alice: Boiled eggs in the morning.
Alice: 中午
Alice: At noon...
Shure: 中午炒个鸡蛋吧
Shure: Let's have scrambled eggs for lunch.
Alice: 晚上鸡蛋的妈
Alice: And eggs for dinner.
Shure: 鸡蛋的妈是吧
Shure: Eggs for dinner, right?
Katrina:  吃鸡
Katrina: Eat chicken.
Lucia: 哎有人吃鸡吗
Lucia: Hey, is anyone eating chicken?
Alice: 是和平精英吗
Alice: Are you talking about PUBG?
Lucia: 哦对对对
Lucia: Oh, yeah, yeah.
Alice: 很菜
Alice: I'm not very good at it.
Shure: 我们下棋吧
Shure: Let's play chess.
Alice: 下棋下棋
Alice: Chess, chess.
Tasha: 打麻将的呢
Tasha: What about mahjong?
Shure: 打麻将估计费点劲去
Shure: Playing mahjong might be a bit tricky.
Lucia: 但我今天发现
Lucia: But I found out today...
Lucia: 我的收藏夹里的游戏今天打五折
Lucia: That the games in my collection are 50% off today.
Lucia: 我要不要登录一下
Lucia: Should I log in?
Lucia: 先把它拿下来
Lucia: And grab them first?
Alice: Steam吗你玩啥呀
Alice: On Steam? What are you playing?
Lucia: 最近在玩使命召唤
Lucia: Recently, I've been playing Call of Duty.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 嗯我觉得是
Tasha: Hmm, I think so.
Jake: 有没有从旁边拿出来的办法
Jake: Is there any way to get it out from the side?
Jake: 这玩意掀不起来
Jake: This thing won't lift up.
Shure: 有点有点痴心妄想的我感觉
Shure: That seems a bit unrealistic to me.
Alice: 这边那个麻将桌是本来就在那的吗
Alice: Was that mahjong table always there?
Tasha: 很明显
Tasha: Obviously.
Shure: 他不是
Shure: It wasn't.
Tasha: 是被他私藏进来的
Tasha: He smuggled it in.
Alice: 私藏进来的
Alice: Smuggled it in.
Shure: 主要是他
Shure: Mainly him.
Jake:这原来在这
Jake: It was originally here.
Shure: 那就这样吧
Shure: Let's just leave it at that.
Lucia: 我觉得我的这个芍药还能再泡两天
Lucia: I think my peony can soak for another two days.
Katrina:  但压花需要两三天啊
Katrina: But pressing flowers takes two or three days.
Lucia: 但是他现在还没有开
Lucia: But it hasn't bloomed yet.
Katrina:  没有一朵芍药
Katrina: Not a single peony.
Alice: 那你用康乃馨吧
Alice: Then use carnations.
Alice: 你的康乃馨开的好盛大
Alice: Your carnations are blooming splendidly.
Lucia: 对我康乃馨好旺
Lucia: Yeah, my carnations are thriving.
Lucia: 但是芍药好自闭
Lucia: But the peony is so shy.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 我看我之前他还没想开
Lucia: I saw it earlier, it still doesn't want to bloom.
Alice: 我的芍药已经开始谢了
Alice: My peony is already wilting.
Jake: 他能催熟吗
Jake: Can it be ripened?
Jake: 一天速成速开
Jake: Like, fast-track blooming in one day?
Lucia: 你以为这是期末考试啊
Lucia: Do you think this is a final exam?
Jake: 哈哈哈想让来他就开
Jake: Haha, just want it to bloom on command.
Alice: 我想开了
Alice: I've come to terms with it.
Lucia: 想开到一半就自闭了
Lucia: It wanted to bloom halfway but got shy.
Shure: 我决定我今晚也熬一次夜
Shure: I've decided to pull an all-nighter tonight.
Katrina:  为啥呀熬夜可难受了
Katrina: Why? Staying up late is so tough.
Shure: 然后把那什么弄完
Shure: To finish that thing.
Shure: 这样就没有顾虑了
Shure: Then I won't have any worries.
Jake: 把那什么那什么呀
Jake: Finish what exactly?
Shure: 把我的毕设
Shure: My final project.
Shure: 我的必设报告就剩最后那么一neinei
Shure: My final project report just has a little bit left.
Jake: 好那你直播做毕设
Jake: Okay, then livestream your final project.
Jake: 是压出来了吗
Jake: Is it pressed already?
Katrina:  哈哈哈怎么压的来
Katrina: Haha, how did you press it?
Katrina:  变干瘪了
Katrina: It's all shriveled.
Shure: 他压出了不一样的风味
Shure: It has a different flavor when pressed.
Jake: 压花嗯
Katrina:  怎么跟
Katrina: How come...
Katrina:  跟网上的不太一样
Katrina: It's not the same as the ones online.
Jake: 网上长啥样
Jake: What do they look like online?
Katrina:  难道是要把它那个花瓣一个个剥下来
Katrina: Should we peel off the petals one by one?
Katrina:  然后那样子压吗
Katrina: And then press them like that?
Katrina:  然后如果整个压花的话
Katrina: And then if we emboss the whole thing
Jake: 花瓣大
Jake: The petals are big
Lucia: 我让我查查有没有什么攻略
Lucia: Let me check if there are any guides
Katrina:  搜一下压花攻略
Katrina: Search for embossing guides
Jake: 好笑
Jake: Funny
Jake: 嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay
Tasha: 好无聊呀
Tasha: So boring
Jake: 来压花
Jake: Let's do some embossing
Tasha: 下棋吗
Tasha: Play chess?
Tasha: 找不到事干
Tasha: Can't find anything to do
Shure: 老板他要摸鱼
Shure: Boss, he's slacking off
Jake: 收拾收拾跳跳舞
Jake: Tidy up and dance a bit
Jake: 今天也没啥事
Jake: Nothing much today either
Jake: 收拾收拾房间好拆点快递
Jake: Let's tidy up the room and unpack some deliveries
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Jake: 快递还没到
Jake: The delivery hasn't arrived yet
Lucia: 开始装修房子
Lucia: Start renovating the house
Jake: 对快递还没到呢
Jake: Yeah, the delivery hasn't arrived yet
Tasha: 工具还没到呢没办法装修
Tasha: The tools haven't arrived, we can't renovate
Lucia: 到了一个
Lucia: One has arrived
Jake: 那就等那我问问快递什么时候到
Jake: Then let's wait, I'll ask when the delivery will arrive
Jake: 呃或者再开个小车过去
Jake: Uh, or we could drive a small car over
Lucia: 对我今天应该还有一个快递
Lucia: Yeah, I should have another delivery today
Lucia: 京东还是快
Lucia: JD is fast
Lucia: 淘宝上那些
Lucia: Those on Taobao
Lucia: 我就希望他明天能到
Lucia: I just hope it arrives tomorrow
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 那个
Jake: That
Jake: 那要不集体玩狗去也行
Jake: How about we all go play with the dog instead
Shure: 集体遛狗
Shure: A group dog walk
Shure: 哈哈六个人一起撸狗是吧
Shure: Haha, six people walking a dog together, right?
Lucia: 狗都薅秃了
Lucia: The dog will be bald
Shure: 狗屎
Shure: Dog poop
Lucia: 狗在哪
Lucia: Where's the dog?
Jake: 要走多久啊
Jake: How long is the walk?
Shure: 200米吧
Shure: About 200 meters
Jake: 那可以那可以去玩狗去
Jake: Then that's fine, we can go play with the dog
Shure: 狗说你们才是真的狗吧
Shure: The dog says you guys are the real dogs
Lucia: 哈哈哈我可能不是人
Lucia: Hahaha, maybe I'm not human
Lucia: 但你们是真的狗
Lucia: But you guys are really dogs.
Shure: 你说你说
Shure: Go on, go on.
Shure: 这句话怎么给南洋理工同学翻译呢
Shure: How do we translate this for NTU students?
Lucia: 没事新加坡中文普及率应该很高
Lucia: No worries, Chinese should be quite common in Singapore.
Lucia: 官方语言之一
Lucia: It's one of the official languages.
Shure: you you you are
Shure: dog ban dog是吗哈哈哈
Jake: Doggy Doggy dogger
Jake: Doggy Doggy dogger.
Shure: 刀哥刀哥
Shure: Bro, bro.
Jake: 就是他们也有那种表情包嘛
Jake: They also have that kind of meme, right?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: doge是吗
Shure: Doge, right?
Lucia: 嗯哇这是好多年前的表情包了
Lucia: Yeah, wow, that's a meme from many years ago.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 咱们这个就这么放着
Shure: Let's just leave this here.
Shure: 谁干的
Shure: Who did this?
Lucia: 我昨天忘洗了吗
Lucia: Did I forget to wash it yesterday?
Shure: 谁干的
Shure: Who did this?
Jake: 来我们一人洗一个
Jake: Come on, let's each wash one.
Lucia: 啊谢谢你
Lucia: Ah, thank you.
Jake: 一人洗一个
Jake: Each wash one.
Shure: 我的我的衣服好了
Shure: My, my clothes are done.
Lucia: 你啥意思
Lucia: What do you mean?
Jake: 你的衣服做好了
Jake: Your clothes are done.
Shure: 没事我我
Shure: It's okay, I, I...
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks.
Shure: 我今天早上那个外面
Shure: This morning outside...
Shure: 的谁的衣服掉了
Shure: Whose clothes fell?
Lucia: 这要不要泡一会再洗之类的
Lucia: Should we soak it for a while before washing?
Lucia: 但这里面有有油
Lucia: But there's oil in it.
Lucia: 给他泡到
Lucia: Let it soak.
Shure: 无所谓
Shure: Doesn't matter.
Shure: 操
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 怎么有纸屑呢
Shure: Why are there paper scraps?
Shure: 我兜里揣纸了吗
Shure: Did I put paper in my pocket?
Lucia: 抱歉
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 我昨天晚上的邪恶计划没实施了
Lucia: My evil plan from last night wasn't carried out.
Lucia: 后来忘记了
Lucia: Then I forgot.
Lucia: 哈哈大反派忘记了他的邪恶计划哈哈
Lucia: Haha, the big villain forgot his evil plan, haha.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 青春献给谁
Shure: Who are you dedicating your youth to?
Lucia: 这个是方的
Lucia: This one is square.
Lucia: 不太好用
Lucia: Not very useful.
Lucia: 只有那个稍微好用点
Lucia: Only that one is a bit better.
Jake: 我们那个金币是谁买的呀
Jake: Who bought our gold coins?
Jake: 就是拍卖用的金币
Jake: The gold coins for the auction.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake: 爆金币爆金币
Jake: Explode the gold coins, explode the gold coins!
Lucia: 哎我记得那天是谁说用贴对
Lucia: Oh, I remember who said to use stickers.
Lucia: 贴画就可以来着
Lucia: Stickers will work.
Lucia: 对所以应该是本来就有吧
Lucia: So we should already have some, right?
Lucia: 好像是雨轩
Lucia: I think it was Yuxuan.
Lucia: 问问雨轩好
Lucia: Let's ask Yuxuan.
Shure: 行不行咱们踩点纸壳子就行
Shure: If it doesn't work, we can just use cardboard.
Lucia: 可以有人要做狗吗
Lucia: Anyone want to be a dog?
Lucia: 不是有人
Lucia: Not anyone.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 我们都很狗
Jake: We're all dogs.
Shure: 把把把狗
Shure: Woof, woof, woof.
Jake: 我们都很狗
Jake: We're all dogs.
Lucia: 有人做狗吗
Lucia: Anyone want to be a dog?
Shure: 狗弄完之后
Shure: After we're done with the dog.
Jake: 然后我们承认我们很
Jake: Then we'll admit we're really...
Jake: 我们可以做狗
Jake: We can be dogs.
Lucia: 就这个狗吧
Lucia: Just this dog.
Lucia: 他可以他就是他
Lucia: He can, he really can.
Lucia: 可以做的好一些
Lucia: He can do it better.
Lucia: 可以做的那个潦草一些
Lucia: He can do it a bit sloppy.
Jake: 那做狗吧
Jake: Then let's be dogs.
Jake: 今天我们一起做狗
Jake: Today, we'll all be dogs.
Lucia: 今天我们一起做狗
Lucia: Today, we'll all be dogs.
Jake: 我们今天先玩狗
Jake: Today, let's play with the dog first.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 到时候放
Shure: Then we'll let it go.
Lucia: 不是跟狗杠上了是吧
Lucia: Are we really challenging the dog?
Lucia: 一会要撸狗是吧
Lucia: Are we going to pet the dog later?
Jake: 先先玩狗
Jake: Let's play with the dog first.
Shure: 我我们给他做一套铠甲
Shure: We'll make him a set of armor.
Lucia: 哈哈哈那这就交给您了
Lucia: Hahaha, then that's up to you.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我这个难度有点高
Lucia: This is a bit difficult for me.
Lucia: 对我觉得我们这纸箱还是挺多的
Lucia: Yeah, I think we have quite a lot of these cardboard boxes.
Lucia: 需要有
Lucia: We need to have...
Shure: 我们中午吃什么呢
Shure: What are we having for lunch?
Lucia: 尺子
Lucia: A ruler.
Jake: 中午还能吃什么呢
Jake: What else can we have for lunch?
Jake: 我们有别的选项吗
Jake: Do we have any other options?
Shure: 外卖是吗
Shure: Takeout, right?
Shure: 我们可以把所有的鸡蛋全给炒了
Shure: We can stir-fry all the eggs.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 弄个柿子炒鸡蛋
Shure: Make tomato scrambled eggs.
Shure: 再加个苜蓿屎
Shure: And add some mock meat.
Shure: 哈哈哈苜蓿
Shure: Hahaha, mock meat.
Jake: 你听到了吧
Jake: Did you hear that?
Lucia: 不是啊什么呀
Lucia: No, what was that?
Lucia: 啊刚刚他说什么
Lucia: What did he just say?
Jake: 先做一个西红柿炒鸡蛋
Jake: First, make tomato scrambled eggs.
Jake: 再做个苜蓿肉
Jake: Then make some mock meat.
Shure: 来吧下棋吧
Shure: Come on, let's play chess.
Lucia: 哇别吧
Lucia: Wow, no way.
Lucia: 从我到哪里都请大家吃一大盘炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Everywhere I go, I treat everyone to a big plate of scrambled eggs.
Jake: 啊我觉得可以啊
Jake: Ah, I think that's doable.
Jake: 最后一天我们就这么做吧
Jake: Let's do that on the last day.
Lucia: 啊那我只负责炒西红柿炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Ah, then I'll only be in charge of the tomato scrambled eggs.
Lucia: 木须肉我不会做
Lucia: I can't make mock meat.
Jake: 那行那我
Jake: Alright, then I'll...
Jake: 那你会做木须肉吗
Jake: Can you make mock meat?
Shure: 我道理差不多
Shure: I know the basics.
Jake: 整点黄瓜
Jake: Get some cucumbers.
Jake: 买点黄瓜去
Jake: Let's buy some cucumbers.
Lucia: 到时候给大家吃了
Lucia: We'll serve it to everyone then.
Lucia: 一个月都不想看见鸡蛋哈哈
Lucia: After a month, no one will want to see eggs anymore, haha.
Jake: 点个
Jake: Order some...
Jake: 要不就点外卖
Jake: Why don't we just order takeout?
Jake: 西红柿炒蛋和木须肉
Jake: Tomato scrambled eggs and mock meat.
Shure: 哈哈哈好的
Shure: Hahaha, okay.
Jake: 哈哈哈咱不做了
Jake: Hahaha, let's not cook.
Jake: 你不是做毕设吗
Jake: Aren't you working on your final project?
Shure: 对我要做毕设
Jake: 哈哈你这毕设
Jake: Haha, your final project.
Jake: 挺美观的
Jake: Looks pretty nice.
Shure: 毕设哎呀
Shure: 我要把我偷来的代码改成自己的
Shure: I need to change the code I stole to make it my own.
Shure: 这个杨老板应该很擅长吧
Shure: Jake should be good at this, right?
Jake: 这个现在已经不偷代码了
Jake: I don't steal code anymore.
Shure: 现在都搞原创了
Shure: Now we do original stuff.
Jake: GPT直接写了啊还还
Jake: GPT writes it directly now, haha.